[Musique]
ça te dérange
que je ne sois pas tout à fait eux mêmes
tu es la fille la plus humaine que j'ai
jamais rencontré
vous
je t'avais demandé de rentrer avant
qu'il fasse nuit j'ai pas vu le temps
passer
anita il faut que tu sois responsable
tué quelqu'un du ning
et toi
tu n'es pas une fille comme les autres
fois il ya un problème tu te souviens
pas de quoi tu parles
il doit trouver dans la décharge donc tu
as tu tombes et de là où c'est que je
vaux pas grand chose alors ça c'est ce
qu'ils veulent te faire croire
je suis pas ta fille je sais pas ce que
je suis moi je le sais tu l arme la plus
sophistiquée de tous les temps
mais ce n'est qu'une enveloppe ni bonne
ni mauvaise
ça ça ne dépend que de toi
[Musique]
je ne reste pas patient
en présence du mal
elles menacent l'ordre naturel des
choses
ce soir on ne lutte pas
chasse
je veux que vous éliminez cette fille
qu'on appelle à l'italie
[Musique]
vous avez connu la pire erreur de votre
avis
laquelle
vous m'avez sous-estimé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]